david marcus just wrote an amazing piece
for the new york post
calling for an immediate end to the
city's lockdown we're happy to have him
on tonight david marcus thanks so much
for coming on so
if you would just summarize for us why
you wrote this piece and why you think
these lock downs which we've been told
day after day are so important
should end i wrote this piece
this weekend when i saw images of new
yorkers at about 4
30 in the morning hours before this
catholic church opened that was
offering food because they were hungry
and they needed food and when i saw
those images
is really when i went from being
frustrated with governor cuomo and mayor
de blasio
to being furious because
people are going hungry small businesses
are being destroyed
jobs are evaporating our kids aren't
being educated
people can't get cancer screenings and
the governor sits there on his tv show
every day
and acts as if what we're complaining
about is that there's nothing to watch
on netflix it's bizarre and it's
infuriating
why do you think someone as ambitious as
andrew cuomo ambitious politicians tend
to pay attention to what the public
wants
are so completely tone deaf oblivious to
the suffering the pointless suffering of
the population why doesn't he get it
i don't think people have much of a
voice right now i mean first of all
they're
they're stuck at home but i think andrew
cuomo is also in a situation where it's
become abundantly clear
that he bungled this particularly in
regard to the nursing homes
in deadly ways and i'm sure that he is
very very
nervous about making any more mistakes
but that's not good enough
we need leadership because the city of
new york is dying
and it has to open now or we're not
going to be able to save it
so i mean from friends and family and
co-workers who live in new york you get
you get reports of midtown basically
occupied
only by vagrants like that's it just
sort of every public space has been
taken over by mentally ill
drug addicts i wonder if a city like
that like what will it take to bring a
city like that
back to functioning
well the problem is that every hour that
goes by
bringing the city back becomes harder
and harder because
every day there's another business owner
who realizes that he's run out
of whatever that capital is that he had
to keep him floating for what is now two
months
that he doesn't have another month that
he doesn't have another two months of
rent
and you can do a ppe and you know i
understand that
bill de blasio thinks that there's some
giant pot of gold somewhere that evil
republican leprechauns are hiding from
him but
there isn't the only way the city gets
back to work is by getting back to work
it's the only way that
it creates the funds that are needed to
do all the things that the city and the
people in the city need to do
and right now i mean do you have any
indication of when this really ends i
mean
have either cuomo or de blasio said
anything that makes you think you know
oh in august this will be somewhat back
to normal i haven't
i mean the city's been through so much
you know so much
over a couple of centuries several
centuries
this really feels like this man-made
disaster
could set it back maybe more than
anything that's ever happened there
i'm very worried about it um this is
very different than 9 11. this is this
is
arguably much more similar to the sort
of bad old days of
of the late 70s and into the 80s that
rudy giuliani was able to bring
the city out of but you're absolutely
right i if
if when these neighborhoods supposedly
come back to life
40 50 percent of those businesses are
gone and people don't have jobs
yeah see here's the thing this has been
economically painful
so far it really has we are very close
to be to it becoming an absolute
economic catastrophe and i have
absolutely no confidence that either the
governor or the mayor
appreciate that fact at all in fact i'm
pretty sure they don't
at some point probably long after i'm
dead somebody smart is going to write a
book explaining how such a great country
got
such horrible leaders which really is
the beginning and the end of the story
bad leadership produces terrible results
david thank you so much for coming on
tonight what a great piece that was in
your explanation
i thought summed it up perfectly
appreciate it